in saskatoon saskatchewan you'll find
four senior citizens making socks
lots and lots of socks talks by bob have
knitted 11
662
as of today
that's pairs of socks which means socks
by bob has knitted 23
324 individual socks 8.8 miles of socks
and they're all for charity
the main responsible for all these socks
is none other than bob rutherford
[Music]
enter bob's knitting machines
these super powered knitting machines go
at 90 turns per second that's pretty
fast
but what makes these machines special
are that they're self-made
i'm an experimenter i just build things
and it took a long time to figure out
how to do it
but when you're retired and nothing to
do
it just sort of grew
socks by bob began in 2010 after the
passing of bob's wife edith i was a
caregiver to my
wife before she died and my son came
home and said dad you need something to
do i said well i made these socks on
this first knitting machine
and that sparked an idea making socks
for those in need
but bob doesn't work alone he has plenty
of help
george cuts the tube link
glenn and barney they will knit two
socks by the rule
each week bob and his team need hundreds
of socks that they then deliver to
countless homeless shelters all
throughout canada the fox are delivered
in alberta saskatchewan bc red deer
calgary some have gone to the northern
part of the province in short they go to
where they're needed
people gotta keep involved
you just can't give up because of the
reading
or whatever the case may be i think that
knitting socks for
needy people is important people have to
reach out and touch each other i think
that they grow older
and
this has helped me do that
and i think that's
the key to life
you don't give up and find a purpose
find something that needs to be done
and do it
[Music]
you